imagine as you're walking down the
streets thoughts pop into your head
picturing a stranger naked imagining
having sex with your boss jumping in
front of a train they're upsetting
intrusive thoughts but imagine they
don't just go away they get stronger
more disturbing graphic sexual and
violent thoughts they make you question
who you are stuck on a loop inside your
head
this is OCD but not as you know it
loads of people think they know what OCD
is all about as that joke that
somebody's quite organized or tidy
they're a little bit OCD but I started
coming across posts and blogs and there
seem to be a secret side to this a
hidden form of OCD and often people
would start suffering with this when
they were very young and they would live
with it for decades so we've decided to
go and meet some of the people who
suffer with this condition
it pretty much happened overnight I was
15 years old and I was having dinner
with my parents my brother
and that's when I experienced my first
ever intrusive obsessive thought the
mental image that I'd had was a naked
child of a naked little boy and you
don't when you have those kind of
thoughts you don't speak about them I
thought I'd committed some horrendous
act of thought crime just by having had
that thought so it was immediately
something which felt unacceptable and
alien to me and very frightening so
right from the very start it was
something that I was absolutely not
prepared to talk about everything that I
did for 11 and a half years was
underscored by this constant voice
constant doubt constant rapid-fire
mental images now at the time you didn't
he didn't know it was OCD so you must
have you must be terrified I sort of
hate on something recently it the only
way I can kind of describe that terror
is it felt like I I killed someone and I
had a body in the back guard and that's
what it felt like that was the kind of
terror that oh my god I've done
something horrendous I've sort of
thought something so terrible I've
committed an unforgivable sin and my
life is never going to be the same again
that was the terror it was it was it was
it was doom really it was nightmarish
petros socially you'd have no idea any
of that was going on for her under the
service that's probably what makes this
hard to recognize as OCD it's not
obvious like perhaps washing or checking
or cleaning so what makes this OCD and
what's going on under the surface the
content of these sorts of thoughts are
commonly about sex
in terms of being a pedophile also about
violence you know that they might
assault someone or sometimes blasphemy
and in moral question it's just a part
of being human it's normal we all get
ridiculous intrusive thoughts and images
and doubts that just pop into our head
no one with OCD has ever been recorded
to act upon their intrusive thoughts and
images or doubts it just hasn't happened
and there's adequate good treatment for
OCD which means that these thoughts and
worries will go away obsessive
compulsive disorder is a vicious cycle
first unwanted intrusive thoughts occur
repeatedly these are the obsessions they
make the person increasingly anxious
often fixating upon the fear they are
bad or could do something terrible they
feel they must use mental and physical
rituals to cancel the thoughts out these
are the compulsions but attempts to get
rid of the thoughts feeds the original
obsession allowing OCD to tighten its
grip the intrusive thoughts represent a
person's worst fears as opposed to any
desire to carry them out
because of the secretive nature of this
form of OCD nicknamed pure oh no
official data exists but to get an idea
of how many people are affected the
charity OCD action counted the number of
calls and emails they received over 48
days over a third were from people with
violent sexual or religious intrusive
thoughts or who said they had pure Oh
many are scared to seek help in case
they might be misunderstood by mental
health staff or doctors
and that's what happened to Adam a
teacher who's asked to remain anonymous
it's incredibly hard to talk about these
things they're like my absolute worst
fears the example I gave I said there
might be a worry that I'm a pedophile
because that's basically the worst thing
that you can be I know that I'm not it's
ridiculous but it's the worst thing that
I could be so that's why I'm worried
about it he claims his therapist knew he
had a history of OCD and that his
thoughts were distressing not
pleasurable despite this he was reported
to safeguarding services and unable to
go to work the whole time it was framed
as a risk assessment that until I'd had
a risk assessment they couldn't put me
back because they'd obviously been this
red flag waves against me they said look
you're not going to be suspended but we
don't feel it's best you come to school
my initial thought was am I going to
prison it's easily the most traumatic
thing that's ever happened in my life
after being referred externally to a
safeguarding charity Adam was cleared of
all concerns he since returned to work
as a teacher and he says the health
ombudsman is now investigating his
treatment
what does it do to them if somebody's
put through that process and they've got
OCD what does that actually do to them
well at best they may just be very angry
and frustrated by it all at worst it's
going to make their OCD far worse lose
trust in the professionals and may
completely ruin their life in terms of
lost jobs or being taken away from their
children all sorts of nonsense so it
really is disastrous just hearing about
the nature of the thoughts that OCD can
plague you with you can get a sense of
how scary and how how terrifying that
might be but couple that with the
additional pressure of not only worrying
about yourself but having a young baby
and a new family and you can now you can
imagine how OCD takes on a whole
different level so we've come to
Birmingham now to meet with a young mom
who knows and is all about the pressure
of having a young baby and OCD like a
constant 24/7 movie in my head of
everything violent and graphic you could
ever do to yourself or someone else and
if one starts another one starts and it
can be anything you know anything that
you never want to think about something
me her in this tiny newborn baby that
and I'm you're always going to do it but
it was like a horror movie playing in my
head of all the horrible things I was
going to do so I stopped going out
because I was convinced you know I'd put
him out in the middle of a road or
someone would take him I stopped letting
people in in case they did something
when did you finally find out that you
weren't a bad person what Mads you had
OCD two years later add my initial
assessment and they said you know you
tick every box for OCD everything you
have said to us today is OCD and I was
with my first it was like I'm really
messy I don't know just happened like
when you look back now it's so obvious
what was wrong
and I think there was a few missed
opportunities to you know look a bit
deeper than just what I'd come in with
that day so national guidelines do exist
and are in place for how to recognize
and treat all forms of OCD but still
many of the people who spoke to me and
who work in this field feel there just
isn't the understanding of the true
range of forms OCD can take and they are
calling increasingly for things to
change and it's honestly devastating to
hear of anyone that is finding it so
tough but it's also wonderful they brave
enough to speak to you to raise that
awareness I'm worried about those people
that can't come forward or haven't had
the opportunity to have their voice
heard and we can point to some really
excellent services in some parts of the
country but that's not commonplace and
there's also too many examples that I've
heard of where people come forward and
their condition actually isn't
recognized and there is enough awareness
amongst medical professionals themselves
to identify and to ensure people get
proper diagnosis and then proper
treatment and support afterwards in a
really timely fashion I put these
concerns to the Department of Health and
they said to me OCD can be a very
distressing condition and we know that
it takes courage to seek help that's why
we've invested over 400 million pounds
in improving access to treatments we
expect all health professionals to know
and follow national guidelines on how to
care for people with OCD so that they
get the support they need quickly the
true number of people who have this form
of OCD but find it hard to speak out we
might never know but just meeting the
people I have and speaking to them has
given me a completely different
perspective on something I imagine most
of us think or thought we understood but
going back to Rose after years of doubts
and fears she's now found a way to turn
her experience of OCD on its head and
she's using it for something really
positive I get tweets and emails of
people every single day people with OCD
and who want to talk about what they've
been through and and many of them have
never actually told anyone about their
OCD or they use my writing to tell
people about their a CD which is really
really amazing so I just want to read a
couple out for you you gave me the
courage to speak out after years of
keeping it all a secret I finally told
my therapist if it hadn't been for your
article I still wouldn't have spoken out
I've now been diagnosed with OCD and I'm
looking forward to recovery which is
which is amazing and I get I get
messages like that all the time which
really with as cheesy as it sounds
really does sort of brighten up every
day
if you've been affected by any of the
issues raised
you can call NHS one-one-one or contact
OCD action